all right and we are
live the last word with lord cognito and
ibontis
fresh friday morning campfire nice
returning guest east so you know we
gotta we gotta do things right for him
but how are you doing man
i'm doing good this morning um you know
got family in town but they're nice
enough to let me chat with this
gentleman so
we got to introduce him just like we
always do even though he's been here
before we got to do it again
let's do it all right good morning and
welcome to the last word episode 123.
i'd like to introduce introduce a guest
whose skills behind the keyboard
for the last decade have vaulted him to
heights in the journalism world few get
to achieve
with five published books and his own
profile on amazon this
man easily puts this man puts words
easily 10 000 words a day into the world
sorry can't even talk and this guy's a
writer so this is going well
you're good you're good
that that that's right this man
writes for the same magazine of forbes
as all these rich people get to
so how did he get so famous video games
of course so
uh he is no run-of-the-mill gamer though
his knowledge of the looter shooter
genre especially in
is nearly especially in that genre is
nearly unrivaled i'm watching this whole
thing sorry
it's like i wrote it last night and i
was in the building
i don't know scripts are scripts are
hard to oh you're good
fully do he is no run-of-the-mill gamer
his knowledge of the looter shooter
genre
especially is nearly unrivaled along
with his play time i'm sure
from destiny and borderlands to more
time than possibly anyone else in
avengers
you know his articles come back by many
hours of blood sweat and pixels
but he not only covers games and writes
books this man has hot takes on tv shows
the same day they are released
wherever does this man find the time and
he's honestly written over 7 500
articles
1400 in 2020 so far to top it all off
this man
not only started his own youtube channel
it was successful in mere days all
without even needing a fancy intro
he has also amassed a following on
twitter that ensures forbes keeps paying
him the big bucks
so make sure you keep clicking those
links finally if you're curious about
checking out his the
game he covers he will make sure you
know the top 10 things he wishes he knew
before he started
so without further ado let's welcome
back a great friend of the show mr paul
tassie how you doing sir
hey what's going on brother i appreciate
that thanks for thanks for all the kind
words that's
that's that means a lot i always love
these intros
it's my favorite he got you last time so
i had uh i had to trade
yeah that's great thank you yeah i
literally counted up i was like
you have literally written over 7 500
articles at least on forums that was
like since 2010 that can't be true
that can't be true there's no way i
added i trust me i was in there with my
numpad counting them up last night and i
went 20 20 and every 20 20
2010 every month up it was 1400
this year wow oh okay yeah
total yeah okay i could see that yeah
totally yeah they've really gone up for
the years has gone on oh yeah you can
see like 30
30 30 every month it's like a daily
thing that jumps to like 50 so you're
doing two and then all of a sudden
you're like hundreds every every month i
was like damn
i dropped i dropped everywhere else i
was writing for i used to write for a
bunch of sites and then i'm like i'm
just gonna do forbes so that's
a time at five five six a day now for
them so that's so crazy
nice nice man what's been what you've
been playing what's been taking up the
most uh the majority of your time
waifu simulator tension impacts kitchen
[ __ ] i don't call it that birthday much
less
like scandalous game than everyone
thinks it is like
it's it's a lot more family-friendly
than i was envisioning it was
so for those who don't know yeah i don't
it's very addicting
it is it looks like a chinese clone of
breath of the wild which it kind of is
um is a free-to-play open world rpg
that's the environment looks like breath
of the wild and but the characters are
just like straight anime characters
um and i i didn't really it wasn't
really on my radar but
miss 5000 watts and cathalian were like
really hyping it up
and i just downloaded it was free and i
gave it a shot and i was
deeply surprised by how much it offers
for free
um it is a gotcha game so there's like
polls and you spend money on it
but it takes a long long time to really
feel
like kind of that pressure you probably
get you know 20 30 hours into it before
you even
really have to consider spending money
and even then you really don't it just
kind of turns into a daily login
like get your bounties done kind of
thing and and new story missions and
stuff are added in time and it's it's
really fun combat's great
uh it does not have weapon durability
which gives it
like we're gonna go to the wilderness
chat is already starting to agree with
you too shout out to uh
well in broader
he could not stand that about the weapon
durability so when you said that i was
like
i mean for some people if it's like
you're like hey i got a cool weapon but
i'm afraid to use it
that was even for me like the few i
didn't actually beat the whole breath of
the wild
because breath of the wild horizon and
destiny were all too close together
but yeah that was an issue for me and
it's probably something as a zelda guy
i'd probably get over but i could see
like hey i got a cool weapon but i don't
want to use it
that kind of defeats the purpose of
getting a cool weapon but i guess they
do probably drop a lot
of strategy i know i never got that far
in so i was like i know a lot of people
love it no but i understand it the
the one of the knocks for some people
it's definitely that and um
i get it i understand that that
viewpoint you know i disagree but
i i understand people like hey man i
worked hard for this weapon i want to
use it multiple times
i don't know it just made me just
actually made me a little bit more
diverse with my weapon selection
but i i completely understand for those
who have that frustration
how big is how big is like incheon's
world
compared it's
yeah compared to breath of the wild it's
i think it's smaller right now except
the thing is is they're adding a bunch
of new zones so like i think there's
going to be seven zones in total and
there's only two out right now
damn and one of the two is really big by
itself so
at a certain point it definitely will be
um bigger than breath of the wild just
by default
and with how much money it's made it
they're probably gonna be
investing in this and adding stuff to it
for a really long time so
well they've already had how many like
20 million downloads or something that's
all
and that's probably at least 20 minutes
and that's just on i think that's just
on mobile yeah
i don't even know we don't even have pc
in like ps4 data yet so
it's it's huge yeah and the big deal is
that it's huge outside of
of asia so i think it probably just hit
i think everybody was so
desperate because everybody's playing
stuff like among us i know softball guys
dropped recently but there was just like
there was nothing and it was free and
they're like all right i'll try it and
sure enough
worked pretty well yeah well nothing
happened in destiny so i'll just wrap
this up
slowly slow slow week
let's get to it uh but yeah
we've we've gotten to know this man
before so we can jump into the destiny
stuff
um nice pieces we have a lot to talk
about every time we like
schedule guest out and i had like you
know paul on the schedule a few weeks
out and stuff and i was like okay let's
narrow it down
and i'm always waiting to know what's
going to come and of course we get paul
when there's way too much to talk about
so it's good
festival lost we got to start there at
least go in order um
i've seen many thoughts on like
strategies about ciphers idle grinding
on my own
just curious how you guys thought about
it if you care if you're digging the
armor
just what are your thoughts about what
you've seen so far and of course paul
you're first
you're the guest um
yeah it's it's not amazing uh it's
i think they had to improvise at the
last minute because i don't think this
was the original plan
because mercury is not even supposed to
be in the game
uh if beyond light wasn't delayed so i
think they really had to
kind of just rip the whole thing from
last year which is why we're getting
things like
750 uh drops like from chests and things
it's just
a lot of it is not caught up um
though i i will say the armor the
eververse armor is extremely good
probably one of the best holiday sets
they've ever done it's it's amazing
i wish in a perfect world that was
something you could earn from the
haunted forest and like get drops of
that that would be cool
but that is not the world we live in um
the cypher system is very not really
well thought out i don't think
i i mean the rates initially were just
so bad that they might as well not
have even existed um now they're a
little better but it's still
you gotta do like five six seven eight
activity completions of some sort to get
a full five to
make one run of the haunted forest which
yeah
i i don't really understand that logic i
don't know why they didn't just do
um you know more the more branches you
clear the more chess you get the more
shots you get of stuff
um and then i don't really like the loot
either like
i don't um it's kind of sad to not have
even like one new reskinned
gun that was new uh so we have the old
re-skinned ones
that the perk pools are like okay but
there's so many better
auto rifles already that it just the
only thing i'm going for
are the is the triumph to get the
different exotics and then the
spooky emblem and whatever this mystery
consumable thing is that you get at the
very end of all of it
uh i've heard about it but besides that
yeah i i don't know what it is i can't
tell if that's a big deal or nothing
but it's it's interesting um
it's some sort of like ascendant lens or
something yeah it's not like no one
knows what it does
yeah i don't even have not been able to
figure out if it does anything or not
but it takes up space in your inventory
which is definitely not something
you look like the monopoly guy that's
all it is well i
it reminds me of like the the tinkatur
tincture of queen's fire whatever it's
called where it's like you can see into
the ascended plane or something
but yeah i don't know if it actually
like i haven't heard anyone finding
anything with it um and i feel like
somebody probably would have by now so
yeah we'll see
yeah overall i mean i wasn't expecting
much from this event
and besides the armor i don't think
there's really
much to it
cognito what do you think yeah have you
touched it much or
yeah i did i actually got finally got a
chance to play a little bit this week
and um
you know pretty much paul nailed it i
mean it's
we understand the situation here you
know this is content that is literally
you know should have been already you
know in the new season
obviously it's been stretched out things
have to be adjusted you know the
infinite forest is the infinite forest
you go in
you know shoot stuff have a little fun
get a little scare when they when they
chase you
and then you know you get the loot now
the cypher thing is interesting the drop
rates were horrible
so um you know that definitely didn't
inspire me also
you know the fact that it's you know
horror story and you know the bray tech
werewolf
again you know 450 is not in the
greatest place anyway
you know the random rolls i felt you
know the drops could have increased a
little bit
with um with that for for more runs so i
can get more chances to farm specific
roles
but um other than that to be honest the
only reason why i
really dropped in is due to paul because
i saw his tweet
and he's like yo interference updated
i'm like okay cool this is what i'm
doing first
that's like the best thing of the week
right there that was the cool thing this
week yeah
that was the best thing bro and i got
again i saw your tweet and i just like
i i can't wait to see that and you know
the whole nocris thing was cool
shout out to that that was really cool
but as far as you know as far as you
know festival lost i i it's just not my
favorite event historically it's just
not been my favorite event i've never
really cared for it whether it was
festivals of the course they've tried to
get better
shout out to the trailer this year
though the trailer actually fooled me
like
oh the rock trailer was moving like
bungie always does great that's right
so i'm like okay but it's it is what it
is and
like i said we just we we understand the
situation so i'm not gonna go hard on
them
it's it's we just gotta hold the fourth
down until
november 10th come and they get that
extra time but what about you you
you deep dive in there get your spooky
on
that's all i see on twitter right now is
spooky this spooky that i'm like
i'm not doing that i'm just me it's fine
he refuses
i'm not gonna be spooky because it's
gonna change so you guys are gonna be
like turkey people and you know by the
way
random tangent because i'm just sitting
here going through holidays in my mind
did anybody see that weird trailer for
that mel gibson santa movie
yeah oh my god i don't even know what
that was that's anyway yeah go watch
that if you want to
question some life decisions for a
second
no for me like festival is
we had low expectations or at least i
did in the first place because we knew
it's like right before beyond light
they're all focused on that this was
like
2019 save as plus cipher decoders copy
paste go like
it wasn't a whole lot different and of
course as you said paul like mercury is
leaving
this shouldn't have even been in there
because so i honestly wonder it's like
as you said
do did they have another festival
planned for beyond light that we'll see
next year that we don't this time or
i'm honestly kind of curious how that
would play out since mercury would be
completely gone
would they actually send us into the
haunted forest just through like the
tower director even though mercury is
gone like would that be like a patch
download and all of a sudden your game
shrinks like a month later or something
i'm kind of wondering like if it wasn't
if this was even
if this was going to be it anyway i
honestly don't know so
that's awesome yeah but the cipher
decoders yeah i don't know if they could
separate it out or not they could
yeah because i mean do you like you
spawn straight in the forest
kind of in a weird different area and
they just kind of use that environment
we always teleport in
out of it i don't know it could be
somewhere buried in the game that they
might use
i would be happy if this is the last
time we see the haunted forest
we've seen it for six i think
we had the revelry we had this we had
mercury one too many times
over halloween scrooge come on cindy
they call you the scrooge halloween
right now they're going in on you right
now i love it
the chat is cool the biggest thing i
would say is like the ciphers though
because
i figured they would have learned their
lesson in reckoning that you get
something in here that you use somewhere
else and this whole like cross thing
why you can't get ciphers in the haunted
forest
i don't get it yeah i don't get it yeah
in the activity itself that is
interesting even some it doesn't like
the main chest maybe you get one or or
you get a chance and that's like there's
no incentive to go
for more branches is it just like what
should you like stop at five and be done
like is that the most efficient way to
go
interesting design choice i agree not to
be able to farm them
in the activity itself whereas they want
you to do other
activities for a chance to it but shout
out to them for um
at least being you know agile as far as
to drop rates and trying to
patch in i thought that was a very quick
patch so well you were down
yeah how are you guys doing with drop
rate since
i haven't played as much since i did a
couple vanguard strikes and i got zero
and then i saw chevy was doing adept
nightfalls and got like
90 plus percent drop on nightfalls so
it's totally double drops so it's almost
guaranteed from ordeals i think yeah
that's why but
i don't know how many adept nightfalls i
want to run in a row so
i've had pretty good since since the
buff but it's still it's still not what
they said it's not like
umbral rates no because like you're
drowning in numbers but you're still not
yeah because it's only at activity
completion
which is not not enough and i don't
really want to run
you know five to ten activities before
every forest run well and then
i got one on my first strike i got two
of my first two nightmare hunts
my my tolen farm does not really have
seemed to benefited from this
drop rate increase like it just i i did
not have
luck with it the other day so the tassie
trail yes that's my
i love that phrase
it's yeah i i don't know i don't think
that's probably the most efficient thing
to even do anymore
maybe it's nightmare hunts maybe it's a
death knight falls if you have a team
for that like
but it's still like it's it's gonna be
kind of a drag to get to 45 or whatever
you need i think i'm at 20. um it's so i
i don't know i i honestly don't even
know if we'll finish but
so yeah and that's kind of thing is like
if it's one activity completion
and it's like okay over the course of a
month will i get 45 done
that's like 1.5 a day it's not that bad
but also and still
if people want to grind through it
you're asking me to do 45 crucible
matches or nightfalls or nightmare hunts
and it's
i don't know you can't get it everywhere
but it is just very weird that you can't
get any in the forest there's no
incentive and then after you do your 45
nightfalls
then you got to go do you know a decent
chunk of
uh forest runs you got to go do nine
forest runs in between there and you're
capped at 25 so you got to do like
get your 25 go do your five forest runs
then come back out do more
it just seems weird so i'm hoping this
is kind of our last seasonal event of
this
style infinite forest can go again as
we've talked about before is i'm just
hoping beyond light is like all right
we're we're cleaning some stuff up here
just like putting this in the the vault
and just
cleaning the table off it's going to
look prettier when we're done to me
the decipher feels like an engagement
play you know they understand
like i think it feels like they know
that people are not going to be playing
almost in the in the vein of um
like i know this week they've increased
doing the double drops with the
nightfall
all this stuff is trying to just basic
routine stuff that we've been doing to
keep
going and they're just in a tough spot
they're in a tough spot that's just all
it is so
we me you know this is all filler stuff
and we just gotta survive boys it's
gotta survive you gotta push through
that's it we're almost there it's
literally
almost a month it's like a month and a
day yep yeah
it's crazy well festival happened but
interference man uh i wanted to ask you
guys what you thought about that final
mission because
the voice dialogue and everything that
we got in there the final piece of
uh the lore from heiress just wanted to
see what you guys thought actually
playing through that one
i mean i'll jump in if you want um i
thought i thought it was cool i thought
um
i love the the the introduction you know
obviously nocris has been talking to us
the whole time
i like is it call me for wrong if this
is the first time i heard the
the quote taken queen i thought i'd be i
don't know if it was ever
did aaron say it in zavala's office it's
the only other place i could picture it
oh yeah so maybe i'm more i feel like i
heard it at least once
okay well maybe for me it was like i was
like wow this is maybe the first time
they referenced it but if
for whatever reason it resonated
different when it was said but um yeah
it was cool different little mechanic
obviously nakris comes back the whole
thing we get a little
loyalties and stuff like that you know
it was a nice little conclusion you know
i'm saying i didn't i didn't have too
many problems with it um
i think that they're setting up the the
next season i thought this
i think if if this season season of
arrivals didn't get delayed
you know and it ended on time i would
have been okay with that transitionary
piece going in
you know i'm saying to be online but
because we have this weird gap
you know what i'm saying it just made
things a little off for
you know the the flow of the season but
um overall cool i liked it descending
playing stuff i'm always a fan of so
i'm cool with it what did you dig for
yeah i liked it
um i agree with you in that i think this
all would have worked a lot better
if the timeline was on point like
between this and evacuation like
it was very weird to do the evacuation
stuff like a month ago
and have it be like oh it's the
guardian's last trip to
mars and then it's just like there's
like two more months on mars
just chilling so it it it kind of really
screwed up the timeline
um the microsoft itself was really good
i i liked the court of oryx fight
we were getting a lot of dreadnought
hints um between both that event and
then there's stuff the first night in
festival the lost the spider
and house of kings and the facts and
like so i i think we're that's all
building toward
next fall which we'll we'll do over the
course of this year
and um the i really liked the pyramid
statue room i thought that was extremely
cool i had seen that like someone
glitched into that a long time ago so
it wasn't a total surprise but it was
very cool
implies to me that we are going to see
other races probably get
darkness powers stasis um
so i i would say cabal and hive are
probably going to get stasis stuff
eventually or
alter their attacks in some way like
we're seeing with the fallen for beyond
light
and yeah i just i thought it was really
cool um i wish maybe there was some sort
of
actual physical reward at the end of all
this
like this this could have been the end
of some exotic quest or something like
it was a little weird to have lore be
the only thing
at the end i guess you got your
forerunner title which is
its own form of reward uh so that was
that was cool
it's nice to finally get that but
overall i think i think it was really
well done
yeah yeah i actually want to double down
on what you said paul i forgot about
that part which is
the conclusion and you stand there and
you see the races
it almost felt like a chess board and i
like that little dynamic
narratively like you know you had the
guardians one side you know
the cabal i actually liked that it was
it was a nice little touch
artistically so i was i was a big fan of
that i wanted to i forgot all about that
part
that was actually a cool part but what
about you man i was gonna say
conveniently the one that's not in there
is vex and then when we see
like screenshots or the trailer for
beyond light europa we're seeing vex
room around in the darkness ship
so apparently they've been left out of
the darkness's circle
or something like then there's like can
never remember the pronunciation it's
like queer at cora
i don't know it's like yeah you know
what i'm talking about
right q see
[Laughter]
that connection to savithoon who's kind
of sexy
that whole thing um yeah but yeah the
vex aren't in there so
it was kind of noticed that's already
working for the darkness though the vex
were like in season of undying
and like working as the darkness as foot
soldiers essentially
yeah it's true well that was that was
the soul i got yelled at about this
before
it's the soul divisive so it was a part
of the vex
without working with the darkness and
apparently the rest of the facts are
neutral or something so
he was yelled at by twitter
shout out to dcv that's funny but no
that's what you said too and they
actually i feel like they mentioned it
at once at one point bungie did is like
the other races over the course of the
year are going to be seeing
darkness powers potentially get into
kabbalah
yeah yeah that sounds so we're going to
be
yeah i see kira kyrie curia
something like that um but yeah that
actually kind of leads credence to the
fact that like
you know cabal on other planets and
hives sitting on the moon might actually
have some weird transition over the
course of this year
i'm very curious to see what they do
with us getting darkness and then of
course getting even farther into it
through the year
it's going to be strange but yeah we
know what our power level is going to be
and that's about it right now
so and we know some exotics
because they dropped a trail a teaser
for a trailer for the game of the
they dropped so many different pieces to
that so we've got a lot of exotics
do you guys have any favorites before we
go through them all like if you want to
just pick the high notes that you were
digging on first she lacking paul
yeah i like the the titan overshield one
that sounds very cool um that's
i hate barricade normally so i think
that's a cool transformation of that
power
uh i'm curious to see how the sniper
works like as a boss dps weapon if the
lightning strike thing will be actually
good for that
yes uh and then the big stasis ice
cannon uh that it looks cool i'm just
i'm curious to see how that
works in action i'm also i'm also
wondering if that's the raid exotic or
not or if they have shown the rate
exotic or not um
no because i'd say like that looks
really good
yeah yeah man i mean i'm with you the
trailer was on fire i mean
again mark shot to the marketing team
and they always knock it out the park
it's a pleasant surprise you know um
yeah the warlock delegation is very
pleased
yeah yeah the delegation is very pleased
with the poison punches that keep
punching and spreading really i thought
people were mad about the warlock stuff
that they were
that it was that i think people don't
like warlock melee exotics and people
don't like super damage increasing
exotics but i thought the necrotic thing
looked really cool
depending on how strong it is but yeah
normally i i would agree normally
you know we tend to get super enhancing
anxiety that seems to be a warlock
mainstay but um with the that the bug
snacks helmet
um i do like the fact that it also
um it's not see the thing i have the
problem i have with the
super inducing exotics is that sometimes
they're just that and that's only but
what i liked about this one it also had
some
melee regeneration energy synergy so i
also want to test to see if
if besides doing the daybreak super
being stronger
if doing other solar abilities also kind
of work
in conjunction with that exotic i'm very
curious about that i'm speaking to
cactus about that
i'm trying to figure that part out but
um yeah i mean it looked cool the melee
stuff look cool i'm very interested in
that
um titans i'm a little concerned
are you yes so i'm a little concerned um
you guys what if i'm running up on you
and then i just cast an overshield now
i've still got my shotgun coming at you
yeah
i don't know how i can charge you too
yeah
on the go basically one-eyed mask
without tracking that you can just you
know power off when you want so i'm a
little jealous of that
hunters i'm a little fearful of the uh
bleachers all i can say is pair
celestial fire
with necrotic grip huh celestial fire
and necrotic grip yeah i was wondering
if that was well
i hope we have to see if that procs we
have to see if that it's a major doubt
easy there i was trying to figure that
out
is if it's actually classified as a
melee because it for a while it wasn't
counting as a melee correct
but maybe they i thought they changed it
eventually yeah they did eventually
change i remember in the beginning
there's a strong chance it could you
know what i'm saying but i'm interested
in that hunters are going to be scary
man with that
that telewarp like basically giving
hunters blank winning a slight
invisibility
that's going to be you know what it is
it's one of these trailers and updates
that i look at and we talked about it
when we when stasis was debuted
all this stuff looks fantastic all this
stuff looks
like they really have changed the
sandbox and the sandbox is going in this
cool exciting direction
on the flip side pvp i don't know what's
gonna happen bro like
i am terrified of pvp like from a
balancing standpoint
with with stasis in itself now you
have a a a grenade launcher you've got
all these crazy abilities and it's just
funny to me because
like i said from a gameplay standpoint
it looks fun
but i don't know how fun it is to to be
put in stasis i don't know how fun it's
gonna feel you know
i saw somebody on i saw somebody on
twitter saying they're gonna lose their
mind like if i'm frozen
and somebody's like doing an emote next
to me and then like shatters me i'm not
gonna be too happy i'm like
that's exactly going to happen that's
that's exactly how that's you know
people are going to be like frozen
do my little dance and then shoot you
like you that that's there's going to be
so many frozen
trolling montages i that's going to be a
thing 100
what do you feel about the uh the
sandbox stuff up paul like how
how fearful are you worried are you
i mean i would sacrifice pvp balance for
more fun pve
any day so i'm not i agree with you that
i think it
has a lot of potential to be a problem
stasis especially you're right like it
is never fun
to be slowed or frozen and if that's
like the main
thrust of stasis like i think that's
going to get very annoying
very quickly if you're on the receiving
end of that
yeah some of these exotics definitely
feel entirely geared to make
you know classes a little more crazy in
pvp i'm not sure hunters needed
another crazy mobility dodge based thing
in their in their toolkit
yeah like the hundred mobile titan one
is interesting
the titan one is like that it's like a
trials of osiris exotic essentially
where
you get overshields for your whole team
i guess if you
revive them or they revive you or
something so that that seems
like literally just for trials which
yeah i'm not sure about designing an
exotic around that
but we'll see how strong that is in
action
yeah like that one i had questions about
because yeah i hate
hate's probably a strong word i always
if i'm sitting there doing my little
observe videos and i'm always like i'm
not a huge fan of something that
requires me to either be almost dead
or dead to actually trigger same thing
if it's very
like some are very specific to a super
and you build your play style but i was
like
i don't want to plan an exotic around me
nearly dying that just doesn't seem
smart to
get functionality out of and it says
upon revise the titan gains an
overshield lure that protects the wear
in nearby alleys and as you said
it's basically only pvp and trials now
or it's like in a pve situation what do
you do you have to die so then we all
have an aura
and then we can like take more damage
from a boss like that'd be a weird
strategy to like
hey you go get stomped on we res you and
then we're able to survive with this
aura depends on how long it lasts that'd
be a weird strategy to put in but
i don't see this one paying off and then
the other one and also like nightfalls
there's a timer before you can even
revive people
so like it's yeah
i can see that being very confusing like
trying to use that in pve
well maybe maybe they get rid of tokens
you guys have totally froze in the raid
and it's not quite as terrible
oh yeah there was there was a bit of a
stream game back down
here let me try and switch rivers
because
streams okay okay uh
the other one for me those arthruses
which i wanted to ask you is that even
grammatically right
arthritis i don't know how to pronounce
it in the first place and it's like
s i was like really that's so weird but
if it's a name i guess but either way
the double bouncing throwing knife i was
like all i can picture on this
is like a weird montage where you like
bounce it behind
like do a double ricochet but this one
seems i
i feel like somebody's gotta prove to me
that this is good because i don't see it
being yeah yeah
i agree i agree like it looks cool you
know in a trailer
well yeah in a perfectly curved corridor
right
now they did say something to the effect
of um
what is it uh i guess what precision
hits or something increased damage of it
or something like that
did i read that wrong it refers to that
um that weighted knife yeah no
we're trying to figure out what that
actually means it's very confusing like
the wording
is precision so like i can't tell it's
talking about your gun
[Music]
or the knife
it's very confusing yeah very very
confused in that respect so that that's
one of those things
you know i agree with you like
stylistically it looks cool i don't know
in effect until we get more detail
we have it in the wild are we looking
into these weapons gotta talk about what
are the weapons
oh no i was like oh okay we're trying to
get through all the armor i think yeah
okay first we got the ice fall mantle we
got the scars for rez's we got the
dodge which is terrifying because it's
just another way to be invisible and
they blink farther
don chorus looks cool i will say uh g1
crystal i saw her tweet something
it's like it's the same and i saw it was
like this and then she brought up a
picture of a praying mantis face i was
like crap
he's like selling me like bug pictures
i can't unsee it well then you've got
the precious scars it looks like i'm
wearing a seashell that's been shattered
so yes like a big conch shell or
something like that
uh but the one i want to talk about is
the lament we have a chainsaw sword
that one's cool that was like the teaser
picture on like
yeah yeah it's got a little blue and it
said and even the description on it is
so
weird because a mortal blade a stalwart
shield block with the lament to rev the
blades you actually have to block then
shred through shielded enemies and
inside you can actually take out
barriers in the trailer
at its peak damaging an enemy will heal
the wielder so
if it revs high enough and you you know
damage an enemy with it you can actually
potentially get
health back with it like there's a lot
going on with how that thing functions
i'm very curious
a warhammer sword i'm just happy for an
anti-barrier sword
like that alone is yeah game changing to
me
i i cuz you know it that's been a long
time coming so
hopefully some of these others have
anti-champion things too but
you say well we'll talk about some mods
but hopefully a lot of things too
yeah it was interesting for them to lean
into that i felt you know um
i felt they they kind of touched a
little bit of stuff like that when uh
what was it leviathan's breath came out
you know and it had like an unstoppable
intrinsic perk so um
it's interesting you know exotics yeah
like they were doing it for a while
but i i don't know why that went away
i agree i agree um i'm cool with that
you know i'm saying
i'm definitely cool with that i mean
obviously as we'll talk about 12 later
we
there's there's one thing that i we
didn't get i know he knows
i think he we're going to share that
with exotic armor and stuff like i'm
exotic weapons and stuff
oh yeah but um this at least kind of
leans back in that direction of kind of
things we want if they're gonna
introduce these champion type mechanics
and stuff like that
on exotics but um yeah man it looks cool
but i gotta ask paul a question
i've got to ask a question because um
this has been you've been away
and there's been a lot of debates since
uh the
campfire since you said you've last been
here and uh you know i'm going there i
got to ask him i have to ask him
so um as we saw in the trailer uh a
returning exotic came back it was uh
the no time to explain you know saying
we saw the the new functionality and
and stuff like that you know how it
operates so i before we get into your
impression of this specific gun
the debate that has raged on
here at the last word was um in
reference to returning exotics and i
need to get your stance like
how do you feel like for example you
know we know the situation with hawkmoon
you know um luke smith said it's coming
back but clearly it's not gonna have the
one damage you know possible one one or
two tap functionality of the gun
i'll say it like the chatty like it's
time for cog to be wrong we have to see
what side
my van is on falls on so clearly what
side do you levy do you feel
bungie should respect the authenticity
of the gun
and only bring it back in its purest
form
or if they change it you know this this
is
somebody's side you know that it should
be renamed
right or are you okay with them bringing
gums back
if they do something cool or make some
slight change to it
whether it be for balance or any other
purpose where do you stand
on returning exotics
i am okay with them changing exotics
oh dancing let's go you are welcome
every week
all the laughs
okay all right all right i see which
side i'm on now break it down
the reason being is that so many of the
old exotics like
i know they're beloved but they just
aspects of them just wouldn't really
work or wouldn't really feel
right coming back like we have that with
hawkmoon like hawkmoon generated too
many problems with the random bullet
this man and then you think of something
like that by the way i'm just going to
say that
preached a good word don't let him
distract you
you seem like icebreaker where the ammo
regeneration just caught like by itself
caused so many problems that like if
that got brought back
i would rather see icebreaker do like
serious burn damage or something like
that like you know what i mean like
i think there are ways to bring the old
weapons back and to have them do
something new i don't even remember what
no time to explain did
before this and yet i know that any
dimension
nobody got it or not buddy yeah yeah
it never had the buddy all it had was
the re the real
fools that was like the special one that
okay that's what i was thinking
it had recall bullets or something but
it didn't have this floating buddy thing
which is obviously cooler
just by nature so if if they can bring
these back and make them cooler
i think that's a good idea and like with
exotic armor too
i i did a list of like what's left to to
return i think like all the missing
things and
outside of a very few select like
twilight garrison is the one everyone
wants but like
a lot of the remaining old exotics are
just so boring and like
basic that they would almost have to
change them to some extent to bring them
back
to make it worth it and i feel like
that's probably true about about at
least some of the remaining weapons i
think some could probably be
brought back and be fine like myth the
class and and uh
touch of malice and stuff like those
might not need super changes because
they weren't like
ultra broken or anything by the time
they were you know stopped being used
but things like hawkmoon things like
icebreaker like i understand why
that they would change them and not
right change the name at the same time
like i think i think it's okay
to do that so long as as long as the
gun's not just like totally tanked and
like it sucks now and has no identity
i think it's fine to do so no let me let
me in in fairness
in fairness because i have to be fair to
my boy i can't just yes
you know ragdoll him and forte here even
though the the
the good guys won today but just
jokes aside but like what about from the
uh the sp
the purity of the weapon because an
argument that was made
and i do i listen i'm giving any crap
but i do understand this
i do and um you know from a purity of
this weapon people are like hey well if
you do that if you change it the minute
you
change it it should be their argument is
like for example crimson right
it's it's it's uh it's it's different
you know i'm saying it's not exactly the
same so
you know maybe the names should change
they shouldn't call it because
this is a leg that they believe like
they shouldn't call it you know hawkmoon
they should call it something else
because it is
intrinsically slightly changing do you
agree with that or are you still okay
with the name being exactly the same i
mean
hawkmoon i think we're gonna have to see
what the change is
like oh you wanna just wait you're
willing to give it a chance how
nice of you that's kind of awesome that
you're like open-minded
to like give something a chance before
you just rip it to straight that's cool
that's totally cool man continue sorry
no time to explain as an example like
even if that is that's dramatically
changed from the original but i have no
problem with that continuing to be
no time to explain and i mean there's
you could even like explain this away
with lore
as like weapons continuing to be worked
on over time and like getting new
abilities or changes as you know the
stranger
you know did some upgrade and no time to
explain and now it does this
dimensional portal thing or i i don't i
don't even know the lore of hawkmoon
honestly i that's not a story i know but
you could you could write that in
somehow i moved hawkeye such as a
specific example i just don't
i don't know if it's if the new perk or
the new way it functions just totally
has nothing to do with the original
hawkmoon right
then i can see the argument where it's
like all right what's what's the point
of calling it hawkmoon and bringing it
back if it
has nothing to do with the original gun
i'm not even like a big hawkmoon
person because i was on xbox and i
didn't get hawkmoon
until it was nerfed like two years later
so you understand the pain
you understand the pain of never having
it and it's an original form
now we get the clarity as to why there's
no that yeah
a little bit yeah because i don't have
treasured hawk moon memories but
dude it was just a fun argument i i
gotta give crap
i got killed man they killed your
boyfriend i was i was
fighting this fight alone to chat to him
i surprised him
like people are against that no we're in
the minority the audacity community
agrees with ebola so at the time of the
argument
it was all we knew about was hawkmoon
and hawkmoon specifically has one perk
it's luck in the chamber
that was literally all it was because it
was not like an energy or anything it
was a kinetic hand cannon
and it was luck in the chamber and the
whole point is trying to get that little
ping like the double bullets to fire
and they flat out said that's not coming
back and that's literally all it really
had
so that was why i was like okay so if
you're gonna make a hand cannon but it
doesn't do that you could do some other
like
you could call it who know i'm probably
gonna be i don't have a good name off
the top of my head but you could call it
something else
kind of throw a throwback to some kind
of aesthetic for it but not be hawkmoon
but that was literally the only thing
like no time to explain
i'm not even gonna argue i don't mind
that one
because like that's what i'm saying like
because it takes what it was and it
evolved it more
okay because it has the returning
bullets but now it's out of the portal
bullets too so you have like two things
so it like added to it but if you take
literally the one main thing that made
hawkmoon
hawkmoon
right and then now you're going to give
me another hand cannon give me a
different hand cannon what was the
argument at the time but now that we
have more of these to look at
that's always like no time to do this
kind of make pvp suck though like
because it was just it was just rand
like it reduced so many gunfights to rng
like who gets the ping like isn't that
why they're taking it away in the first
place
well potentially yeah but you've also
got something to where was like
if you were normally using it your risk
was at some points you would get those
shots but other times you're just using
a normal hand cannon
so it's like you were you had some ups
and downs because it was
you might win a gunfight you might lose
it but you had the chance to win it
because it wasn't exotic as opposed to
if it wasn't active and you never got
that lucky bullet you were just firing a
hand cannon you better hope to hit head
shots that was
i liked the way the gun felt but it was
like when it procked that was all it did
so yeah that was my only argument i'm
not going to take this thing to the
like you know forever dude he's being
nice he's being nice because you hear
he's being
nice i'm telling you i got destroyed i
got
i i'm telling you it was blood sweat and
tears man all right
i'm gonna go back and watch the tape you
got i'll send you the clip it was close
yeah i was in on him at the time because
it was just over hawkmoon
and specifically over hawkmoon again it
is still all it has so that's why i'm
like
i want to see what it does but if it's
like if they take away the luck in the
chamber and it's not doing the damage
right it's not really hawkmoon anymore
so that was just no listen
like i said the last part is that you
know the only reason why they can't it's
just from a balance standpoint
that's all it is they they if they bring
it back exactly how it was
they know the sandbox will be breaking
thus the change is going to happen and
the only point i wanted to make that i
forgot to make last time and then we'll
move on with that distance
was that this has happened before
because people tell me no they've never
really done it before thor and they just
enhanced it
actually it did happen it was lord of
wolves
lord of wolves in d1 when you killed
someone
it gave recovery plus three and the
mentality was a pack
weapon where you would be in a pack and
you get kills and
everyone stay recovered when it returned
in d2 it completely changed
it had nothing to do with that pac
mentality so there
are exams not a lot but there are
examples where they fundamentally change
the weapon
no one was screaming what it is is a lot
of destiny fans
we have to admit we have the guns are
designed so well we have this emotional
attachment and i get it you know what
i'm saying same thing with icebreaker
but if icebreaker was to come back
you can't have an infinitely
regenerating sniper rifle
in this sandbox it would completely
break it
thus it can't come back in its exact
form
and that's like again when it is one
truth
and i get it but i was like lord of
wolves still fired the way it fired
correct
it did it it intrinsically doesn't do
the same thing sir
it doesn't do the same thing look i i
have nothing right
we
uh you guys did mention cloud strike
though that sniper i am curious because
pvp i can see like some very good
snipers just
absolutely making chaos of lightning
storms in there but the rapid precision
shots for boss damage you mentioned it
perfect paul is like
how well is that going to compare for
dps on a boss i know there's going to be
data in there saying does cloud strike
compare to all these other snipers in
boss damage because
you know there's going to be it's like
all right so with this clip and the
reload rally barricade and if you just
keep making lightning storms over his
head how's it go
so we will just have to see but that one
actually does look fairly cool
i think that's the design of that is
wizard
or yeah that actually looks like a staff
more it's just a frame is built around
it
i'm not entirely sure what we fire out
of the gun because it does look like
there's no barrel
we'll just have to see i assume it's
it's an energy
sniper so it'll be like an arc energy
sniper
technically we shoot lightning bolts out
of a rock yeah
yeah i'm wondering what the effect will
be if it'll like shoot lightning or if
it'll just be like an arc bullet but
yeah yeah i'm hoping snipers as a as a
classmate really get buffed
i really do i i i miss snipers really
having that potency in the sandbox so
they bring this this thing looks cool it
has a lot of potential you know i'm
saying that i would love
that um know buff to go alongside with
it so we shall see but
sandbox patch notes come out and and
snipers are hit down another 20 percent
everybody's just like come on
come on come on i was like they can't go
down any lower they already don't
compare with pretty much anything else
they need to
they brought them up and we're like they
got used now and then they took them
away and were like why and they still
haven't come back so
i do not understand that's one change
i'll never understand this
is why they did that because they were
they were like in a really good spy pve
bro same thing man same thing i i really
it really sucks to see where snipers are
right now hopefully
like i said we get some balance back and
also they said uh because of the dcv
didn't they say that that should
hopefully improve
patch
you know so we'll see what happens but
yeah that would be exciting to me
because i really would love them to make
those changes be more agile in the
sandbox
well speaking of uh sand and dirty areas
that's a horrible segue uh you guys
excited to meet our
i was like that's terrible i'm just
sitting here looking at a picture and
it's like the um
i can't even remember the place we're
going to the cosmodrome i'm looking at
like a
dirty rocky area are you guys excited to
meet shaw
han i love was it you who did the uh
shaw hand fast and furious like yeah
yeah that was perfect by the way that
you nailed it so
we're gonna get our new light guardians
and it's a quest we're gonna get to go
on too
we're gon they're gonna get a a guide a
guardian guide to go wander on the
cosmodrome and learn all about the new
light stuff
uh i'm excited about this one just for
the fact that hopefully new light
players have an idea what's going on as
opposed to here's a mission here's the
tower go get lost like
i feel like that's kind of what they had
before now we're at the point of
you get to go through progression you
get to see what engrams are like and
you're gonna be on cosmodrome they said
for
a little while at least multiple
missions things like that before you
ever go anywhere else
so it does seem like i mean they had to
do something they were ripping out like
half of the year one campaign and
everything else but it is kind of
interesting that they actually
we have a new npc now which is kind of
cool i wonder if he's gonna like
actually fight alongside you or just
send you along to do stuff what do you
guys think
i would be surprised if he fights
alongside you because they
i mean we have never really had anyone
truly fight alongside us as an npc
um we have like zavala and saint doing
their bubbles but
yeah they have they have yet to like
actually really have moving enemies that
like
come with us i've been hoping for that
for years but i would be surprised
what about you you excited for our new
buddy yeah i mean i'm excited for to be
honest i'm excited for the concept of
this because
you know as i've been telling you know
i've been talking to you about it
you know with uh beyond light and and
just destiny going into game pass
all i can think about all i get hit up
on twitter you know for the guys that
know me as a destiny guy
hey you know i'm looking to get back in
you know what do i do and and we know
historically
bungie has always had an issue with
onboarding right
and i think they did a good job with
shadow keep initially
with doing the free-to-play and then
everything's kind of a la carte so that
you don't have to
necessarily you know be disassociated
can't play with your friends on the new
content
if you're new so but i like this because
it's it's a little bit of hand-holding
it's getting you acclimated because the
worst thing for a new
destiny player as you go into the tower
there's a thousand icons there's a
thousand vendors you don't know what to
do and people
they generally get lost so i like this
aspect you know as long as they keep
this in the spirit of once this is
completed
whether they get some blues that put you
at the new light level to say okay
you can now do beyond light with your
friends because the worst
feeling in destiny is again i get a lot
of new players that say [ __ ] i want to
play with you
destiny looks cool man i'm in and then
it's like damn
now i got to go do this content and
forsaken and
the red war and you know like that just
separates the base you want to be able
to play
with your friends old and new at the
same time if possible
so if they can do this and on board i'm
with it man this is this is a good start
i i i think this is
necessary for the community and i'm
actually curious myself i'm going to
create
a you know a new uh i'm actually going
to make another character instead of a
damn warlock all day
and um and actually do it and try it i
want to see how this is implemented
yeah my question about this is i'm
here i i so like i know there's this
onboarding process
yeah but what happens after
like so there's all these questions or
you know those quests about like oh this
is how you do weapons this is like
banshee is and what bounties are like
it's it's going to be a lot more of a
walkthrough which is great
but like you get to the end of that and
you're like all right like i get
everything i'm ready to start the
campaign and like
there is no campaign like all of that
stuff is
is gone now so there's no more red war
there's no more warming or curse of
osiris or any of the year two
stuff so unless i'm missing something
like there is
unless there's some elaborate cosmodrome
campaign we don't know about that
that comes kind of after the onboarding
it's more it's more like a free trial
now where it's like okay you get to
learn the basics of destiny
but then for any actual story content
forsaken shadow keep and beyond light
unless you're on game pass you would
have to pay for that individually
right and because otherwise
it's just gonna be like you have access
to i think
strike playlists and crucibles and
gameplay list you're going to get a
bunch of
random storylines from you know all the
different years that aren't going to
make any
any sense individually at all so i i'm
i'm just wondering what the process of
like
actually playing the game after the
onboarding process is going to be like
or if it's gonna feel like a big pay
wall like
now you gotta pay 20 bucks for forsaken
or else there is literally no story
content
i think you're into something you
actually nailed something i didn't even
think about you know
you're right for a non you know game
pass person or a person who
you know didn't buy any content remember
with free to play the red war was there
as a base
introductory introductory thing and now
that that's gone
what do you think e do you think you i
don't think they give them beyond like
bishops as a star what what they give it
for the guy that didn't buy and doesn't
have game pass
it's weird because you could i mean
forsaken's couple years old
so i'm sitting there thinking maybe they
make forsaken free
because you've got a couple other desks
i don't again they need to give like
free if they still want the free to play
model
to bring people in as an introduction
but the other piece of that is
if they go free forsaken because that's
the oldest content
right how thrown off are you going to be
if you jump in
the first mission is cade writing this
thing down
then he dies they don't even know who he
is right and then they go through like
the
they're like who's aldrin what's this
guy like how are they gonna even have
any
care about like whatever campaign they
step into if they go to
shadow keep as well it's like if they do
as you said say they do have to pay 10
bucks because it's like second oldest or
second newer content
and they're like who's eris like i know
they don't get a whole lot of
introduction to these characters and
there's no history from destiny 1 which
is
fine some of us wouldn't want to have it
but kade was in like the red war
campaign and he was in the expansions
and he was hanging out
like you could still go talk to him and
now the fact that like first thing
you're going to do is see him die at the
start of forsaken
that's a good that's weird the only
thing i can think of
is unless they do like a version of
remember when we got
d2 for the first time and you know
we had our we didn't have our save data
carrier of course but our character
was but it kind of gave us this like
historical timeline yeah
of you know on this date you did this
raid on in this obviously
these guys ain't going to have that
memory unless they do some type of a
storyboarding
yeah that would ultimately be the thing
to do right and say okay
guardians did this they defeated the
great gaul
and then you kind of lead in so at least
the new guy says okay this is where the
narrative
is and then cinematically and then now
we can we can
plant you here because you're right you
made a great point there's going to be
no context for cade's death for a new
guy like
he's like okay who's this guy okay you
know there's no contact so yeah this is
a good
this is an interesting for you you'll
understand because it is an interesting
dilemma
for a new player who does not buy
any content who is not over on game pass
and if he didn't buy anything and he
just wants to test destiny after this
introductory mission is over
what is he doing that what is he doing
for free
so that that's going to be a good
question from a narrative standpoint
from a story standpoint because to jump
into
strikes willy-nilly and like that makes
no like he's not going to have any any
any kind of context there so
i think there's no free raids anymore
either there were five free grades
and now there's none so i mean i've
always
assumed they were going to make forsaken
free but we have seen no indication that
they're going to do that and
they're not going to do it if they made
this deal with microsoft to put it on
game pass
so yeah at least for the foreseeable
future it's not going to be free
so weird well it's like and then you
wonder say somebody goes they're like
okay i got beyond light
but they just buy like the base beyond
light thing to like
get into it try it out and they start us
free and that's where they start they're
gonna see a pyramid ship and talk about
the darkness and never have seen shadow
keep
and that's the entire year of the
darkness the arrivals and all that type
of stuff so again the storyboarding
i mean we did go to sushima like when
you had the
i mythical quest or whatever you got to
see the story those were fantastic
bro you gotta be hyped two legends
coming out that deal oh man dude
that game just keeps giving
bro i'm grabbing you up yeah you gotta
do it bro now
ghost tsushima's like just the game just
kept getting better it's so good
um but no just the way they did the
storyboards in there
i know like cinematics are not cheap to
make i fully get that i mean you take
the cinematic from uh
taken king and hell that was absolutely
amazing but
there are times when it comes to some of
these stories like they can't always
have people like biff and stuff put
these things together because
not everybody goes to search youtube
videos some people just want to play a
game and see a story told to them in the
game
and i hope that someday they ever get to
that type of stuff i don't have my hopes
very high because they haven't done it
in six years
but at this point as you said you you
start and then
where do you go this is yeah it seems
like a good thing as a guide to get
accustomed to how some of the function
of the game works
but as for the story i feel like they're
going to be more lost than ever
yeah well one way this would have been
good added on
to the stuff they had you know the past
two years like the problem was not
the amount of content like the amount of
content was the best part of new life
is that you have so much stuff for free
the problem is just pointing people
to that content and explaining how the
game works and now they have the
onboarding
and the explanations but they don't have
the content the free content
great point for your fire brothers
you're on fire man this is this is an
interesting
uh dilemma and hopefully they have
something in place i'm with e man give
me
a go sushima legend you know style
storyboarding or something of cinematic
just explaining what your guardian's
journey has been up until this point
and then say okay then you if you went
through a price sticker at the end and
be like okay for
ten dollars at the bottom you're gonna
join in on if you're gonna like you can
knock yourself out well they gotta
do something i haven't played final
fantasy 14
i know it like launched went away but
there's like i hear people say that like
hey i'm almost through the free stuff to
get to like the current campaign
so it does feel like some of the people
who go in to play that game i don't know
if it's free or not or it starts free
but you can go in and they seem to play
through the older story and they have to
kind of get through that
to jump into the newest like highest
stuff and i know bungie's had the
mentality of like hey i want you to be
able to jump in with your friends and go
but there's also got to be something
said to like go and experience what came
before what's now
and they're kind of ripping all that
stuff away
though it says running through the moth
yards to collect spin metal do you guys
think we're really going to have this
other currency up for earth
i was just like 100 i wanted to ask but
i was like are we really getting spin
metal back
it's going to work like any other tone
like i has to
i'm sure he'll be a vendor it's going to
be this dude who may or may not be
aldrin
uh i was like but you beat me too come
on
let's get it i mean you wrote an article
you got to talk about it that's that's
why we talk about it i did
i regret it it's very weird for them to
introduce
an entirely new character with all the
other context clues
of aldrin just very briefly
like the last update we heard from
aldrin is that he is in the cosmodrome
wearing a helmet as a new guardian like
at baseline oh that alone is enough and
then there's just
there's so many other little clues like
he's wearing
uh young ahamkara's spine and i think
he's got dreaming city pants on
like that directly connects to his old
thing like we know aldrin would probably
be a hunter
just based on his kind of look and vibe
and whatever like if he was resurrected
sure uh it has been a year
since he was all lost and scared at the
dot
at last year's dawning and we think
destiny kind of moves in real time
yeah so people are saying like oh he
wouldn't have a fire team in a year
if he slowly understands being a
guardian i think he would have a fire
team
um this does present more kind of
narrative problems once you get
to a point where if forsaken is the
first thing
that you like players do and they reveal
it to be aldrin at the end of this
you're like wait a minute why am i why
you know why am i killing shaw han in
this
storyline like that would be easier to
kill him become very confusing
yeah so it no like in forsaken like
you you would experience uh aldrin
before
right new aldrin and like they would
have to frame it as some sort of like
flashback or origin story for him
they could that would actually be i
didn't i didn't mention this i thought
of this just now but like let's go that
would be a perfect
segue into getting people to buy
forsaken is he takes his helmet off and
it's all doing he's like let me tell you
a story
and then it's like and then forsaken
is the story and you have to buy it to
see his history
um i'll be fine it would be a pretty big
troll
i think to have all these clues and have
it not be aldrin i know there are a lot
of people pushing back against me that
they don't think it is
and that it's really just some dudes
it sounds like a name you would make up
when you didn't know your own name um
and even before this they had the thing
about like
the symbol for the cosmodrome is the
symbol that was on aldrin's armor and
deep one
yep he initially evidence is over like
i know i've been wrong about aldrin
before when we were predicting if
oh yeah this is the season of the worthy
the guy wearing that helmet oh yeah
secretly aldrin or whatever like yeah i
know that was wrong
i am a lot more confident about this one
i don't i don't know
if it will be revealed in beyond light
or if it might be something in a future
season
uh as a storyline there where uh maybe
he learns who he is we learn who he is
in season 13 or 14 or something instead
of
at the end of this little mini quest
line um so that's that's possible we
might not know when beyond light hits
but i am pretty confident that there are
enough
clues there to point in this direction
but we'll see
i am i'm pulling for this one i i think
this scary sound
you know um yeah it's a lot going for
you man there's a lot of tea leaves go
for you and how cool would it be
because um you know narratively for
forsaken and shadow keep to exist
and and forsaken still be there and if
you know shawahan is him
how cool would that be i it makes so
much sense and then
you know we can hopefully continue his
journey you know coming back and
and taking that spot on the vanguard so
yeah
i'm i'm with you man origin theories i'm
with you all the way
i want this thing to be it you need we
need
clarity we need this narrative to go on
and it would be the
perfect way because him now not knowing
who he is
introducing you the new guardian to the
ways of the light and stuff like that
and it's the ultimate redemption arc
like it is the ultimate
soul you know saying like man i want
this so bad so
what about you he like where are you at
with this no i mean it makes perfect
sense i feel like somewhere there's a
writer at bungie in the fetal position
in the corner and be like how do i make
all these spaghetti stories connect but
yeah yeah shout out to the loyalty
i was like because honestly like this is
i mean we're sitting there like
speculating about all this but they're
probably like
we have a bit of a bind like this is
i don't know how they're going to
connect up this one this is the only
thing in my mind that can make sense or
it's just like
rando npc dude and i feel like most
people that you're going to interact
with
in the game be it asher be it sloan they
haven't had a whole lot to them but
they've had something
so if like this this guy's just gonna be
our cosmodrome vendor and that's all we
get out of them
i don't know it's gonna be weird i
wonder if like the voice actor for
aldrin is like
you know in beyond light or something
like that we get to see it's all those
little things people are getting
into and i shout out i don't know if it
was you paul in your article
um i remember seeing like an old weather
like an
alpha d1 and he was aldrin was actually
introduced in the cosmic drone he's like
pointing the gun at him because he's
like
that was the original story he was
supposed to be
kind of the substitute for the exo
stranger
and i think he was like like
anti-traveler or something
he was a totally different character and
he was in the original trailer
uh i thought they were just going to
straight up like replicate that scene
um but now if he's wearing a helmet it's
supposed to be a secret maybe not but
yeah
i mean he originally was supposed to be
in the cosmodrome so this is
potentially circling back to that too no
doubt i want a shout out we got a
superstar in the chat shout out to the
legendary gamma trap
he said did i miss finding out ivantas
has no taste buds remember that destiny
cooking oh god
we found out all the condiments i tasted
everything that's the problem
we at guardian god that was when we met
you that you know that's what we found
out like the things that he doesn't like
food wise we were eating out
and gavin was gambling chat was on the
show it was fun he was like
you know like this it was hilarious
later moments decisions and it was like
ended up being like 30 minutes of the
podcast with that man
what goes on this what goes here i'm
like
oh i have music so yeah it was good
we'll do dinner next guardian and i can
witness it first
there we go guardian con needs to be
about two weeks long for us to hang out
with all the people that we want to hang
out with like it's insane how many
people to
like interact with it's not gonna be
long enough at all i'm gonna have to get
there a couple days before
we're gonna eat at the rose and shingle
restaurants like all of them four times
if it actually happens i'm honestly
crossing fingers but june
i hope it's all i can do is hope at this
point it still seems like it's
it's it's hopeful i'm keeping help alive
man
yeah so i i don't know cosmic
are very curious they said also like
plaguelands is like
completely off limits due to the
vanguard and stuff like that but they
also said like the cosmodrome was gonna
get fleshed out
yeah exactly oh fleshed out over the
course of i'm like are we opening up
steve again what's happening so
i don't know what's coming next here but
we do know that we are getting
a bit of a change to mods actually um
energy type enhanced mods raids
combat mods do you guys want to just
like start with the can of worms or the
raid mods because that was the one that
i feel like is
a lot of people are kind of a fan but i
know some people who've been grinding
are not so thrilled about this
why are people mad about it i don't
understand why people are mad yeah why
don't you make this you can still
use this i think most people are mad
because they've been doing scourge of
the past like sparrow runs and now it's
for nothing
i think that's the biggest piece is they
just they didn't tell them that long ago
because people have been grinding what
fallen armaments
fallen armaments like any of the fallen
mods come from that one specific run so
people have been doing scourge of the
past runs yeah
they're like hey it's gonna be fallen in
beyond in beyond light go get these
fallen mods and now we're like
30 days away and now we know that
they're like not gonna function as
opposed to
i don't know a while ago that's the one
that i've heard like
i understand completely why because the
prime example they mention is
uh the the mods have been problematic in
gambit and if you take taken mods into
gambit
oh it's absolutely broken because just
worried about this i had no idea this
was the thing
and it explained so much about people
with like eight
truth rockets every time yeah i know i
did not realize that but yeah that makes
a lot of sense now
yeah we're apparently all behind because
i was doing the same thing i was like oh
yeah just throw a grenade on a goblin
heavy i'm i'm like
damn it how did i not think of that so
that's why the taken mods have broken a
lot of things
in gambit which makes perfect sense and
they're just saying uh
starting in season 12 last wish the
garden of salvation
and upcoming beyond light raid armors
will all now drop with a fifth
dedicated armor mod socket that is
exclusive for
mods related to that raid last wish and
garden of salvation armor acquired prior
to season 12
will not have this dedicated armor
socket but will still be able to use the
mods related to that armor or related to
that raid
in the new legacy armor mod socket
so i'll just say the rest of it too
anti-taken
will only work in last wish so that will
still function because they said last
wish was
designed around those mods anti-hive
going away
anti-fallen going away all right that's
everything for the raids so what do you
guys think about
like the old raid armor not quite being
the same as the new
but we also do get a new mod socket
whoever wants to start on that one
i'll tee it up for you um i think it's i
think it's fine
like i i understand the thing about the
runs
but i think you could also kind of see
this coming that armaments were just
too overpowered to like especially if
they were
only available in content that you can't
even do anymore like that
i would have assumed they were either
being nerfed or going away
just based on that alone so i it would
have been nice to know earlier but
i think this is ultimately the right
move i i don't know what else they could
have done
uh i i think the idea is good about just
a fifth slot for mods
um or a fifth slot for for radar in the
future that has more to do with the
mechanics of the raid than like
something that's going to make you
dominate every activity with taken
enemies
indefinitely like that that seems like
problematic design
uh because i mean it was even like the
dungeons like you know there's two
dungeons that are heavily taken filled
like it's
it kind of affected a lot of stuff so i
i
the old raid armor like i get people
were grinding for that too
but again you can still use the legacy
mods on it so i don't think it's that
big of a deal like if you if you have
like a perfect last wish set you could
still use that
in last wish all you want um i'm curious
how energy distribution is gonna work
with
five mods uh yeah or five box slots
because those need to be like zero
energy e and they gotta be cheap
right yeah that's what i'm wondering is
like should they even have energy costs
or should they just
you know you get them you can use them
i've always said that i don't think we
have enough energy slots to begin with
based on all these things
them reducing things like the uh
enhanced mod cost
is going to be a little helpful um
because those were those were massively
expensive those were oh my god half or
more
energy in a lot of the cases so that
that should help a little bit
um i i still think that they probably
need to
be a little more generous with how much
energy you get but that's probably
moving on to
to a different topic we'll get there
don't worry
uh yeah great stuff before we get to
what we segued into already man i have
the biggest smile on this one
this this this was fine like i feel
there's an
ongoing joke here the last word like i
feel the developers always list me
like eve has a point he has a stance
they always go
in his direction but this one not that
she was against this one
but this one was so me i've been
screaming this from the rooftops
i missed the days of getting raid armor
and it
helped you in the mechanics of the raid
i feel a lot of raid armor has been
invalidated
it doesn't have a lot of value and now
we're getting
the depreciation of certain other mods
which i like you know i'm saying the
hand stuff and all that stuff
they get the regular reloaders and all
stuff getting stronger and then the
courses are not going to be as
ridiculous
but this is important because um at the
end of the day
they're showing that connection to the
new raid and helping in mechanics i do
feel luck man i feel for you guys i know
listen i was i'm guilty for one of the
taken last wish you know mod they're
taking mod farming in the last week's
race i'm guilty you know i've been
trying
you know logging in each week getting
two or three chests you know and then
boom
but at the end of the day like paul said
you can't have
these things in the game which is going
to give you
a significant advantage that you can
only get from this source
to now have you doing running prophecy
runs
with this you know leg you know less
taking damage running in gambit
you know all type of it's just too much
of disparity from the halves and the
half-knots
it's just way too much and at the end of
the day i knew this had to happen
so i'm okay with this i'm okay with this
you know with the the older um version
of the raid stuff
look it still has the slot you know i'm
saying i understand people's frustration
there but
this is one of those things man it had
to happen it had to go this way
i'm okay with this change completely and
i'm just i'm back
i'm all about going back to the
mechanics of rays and having that extra
slot so
now it feels special there's something
to be said hey we're doing leviathan
you know hey if you have this chest on
you know when you jump on the plate you
reload faster
those are things i miss in d1 you know
things that really helped in in each
encounter
and bringing that back and like y'all
was saying hopefully
not much of a cost if not free you know
what i'm saying because
if you get that and it gets you to drop
you don't want that taken away
from your other synergies of what you're
trying to do with your build
and the last point um i love the fact
that the reload stuff
they they're taking all that extra rng
of the you know arc or you know oh do
you have the
the arc thing and you have the void
version of the reload all that
deep layers of rng are really
unnecessary so
thank god those are gone too so with
this change
i am super pumped man i really enjoyed
this one what about you
what do you see yeah no i mean to
clarify that's what you guys have both
said it is the weapon oriented mods hand
cannon loader
ammo finders scavengers reserves it
seems like all of those are just going
to be generic mods not related to any
armor so finally
you can use rocket launcher and you know
sword which i know that doesn't actually
make any sense but like you can use it
doesn't matter which one's with
it doesn't matter which is like and they
said we've had this feedback from the
beginning of beginning of armor 2.0 i'm
like
no kidding like we said this as soon as
it launched like
why is this limited we're like oh we
didn't want you to have pages like we
have pages of
everything else 20 different currencies
i think we'll figure this one out so
the fact that they're finally on board
is i'm excited about that one for sure
the enhanced mod rebalancing
take any normal mod that has an enhanced
version it's now the normal mod but
they're also saying they're like
slightly raising the cost of some which
i'm like so you picture like enhanced
hand cannon reloader i think is like
five
normal reloaders three so i picture this
being four four right
but having the the effect of what
enhance would be
right you know that's the key the
potency goes up still
like that's that's i'm with paul on this
one is like either want
more energy to work with be it 12 13 for
i don't know what the number that's
going to balance everything out or
lower the cost of some of these things
because if you go you know if you went
to say you have two weapons and arms are
the only place to get fast reloaders
and now they're both four you can't even
use like a stat mod
on that arm right now because you've
just got you want to work with your two
weapons
and then add on top of that if you're
gonna get raids if those cost more than
zero
you're going to be in a bit of a pickle
there as well so that's the point is
like the cost of some of the mods i know
they want to like
well you need to go a certain build do
you want grenades or do you want to have
faster reloads and it's
they still feel kind of not quite
balanced for
i guess ease of switching stuff around
and messing with builds a lot more
frequently and
just trying to have more fun of the
power fantasy of destiny it's
my joke i mean i'm glad to see like the
fifth socket which is cool because
you'll have to be like
you go on the raid if you wear the raid
armor means you got to have more sets so
we'll see how the vault feels but um
you're gonna have more sets in there but
also the fact that like you go in the
raid you do stuff hopefully you're
better in the raid
we said that like literally probably an
episode or two ago that you get rewarded
for the content that you play
right my curiosity was like i still wish
they would do something like raid armor
if you did go on the raid you're like
hey to use this now you've got 12 energy
i still wish they would do something
like that to have the high
the in-game content to give you armor
that has more energy slots and make that
really an incentive to go do in-game
because if it's just
because somebody the only reason i say
this is somebody commented
some i think it's my youtube video it's
like if he's listening to this like not
ian moore or something like that
um he's like well what if somebody
doesn't raid
and then the raid that the mod that you
get in the raid only works in the raid
so the only benefit is literally
encompassed in that one little thing it
makes the raiders better in the raid
but it gives you no incentive to take
that and use it anywhere else
right so you'll see you would still have
your set of armor that works
outside of the raid and still that one
set of raid armor is still kind of stuck
in the raid
so i can see that too but it is nice to
see raid getting something specific
hopefully we get something on the
weapons as well
yeah uh we also get combat mods i guess
these are all armor and beyond light in
season 12 last wish garden of salvation
basically everything that you acquire
from beyond light launch going forward
is going to have a new combat style mod
socket
these will accept all chart uh charge
with light and warming cell mods
and then the old legacy socket for the
old stuff you've got is going to use
that as well so we're getting
is that like a separate socket from they
said like the generic
like one year soccer did you guys think
this is like the same thing
no no this is the biggest deal this
means this means exotics
can now slot war mine cells and charge
with light mods
so that is actually a huge deal because
you don't have to screw up your builds
anymore if you want to use an exotic
piece so that i'm
i'm probably the most pumped about that
yes
we'll see about other kind of seasonal
mods they do like because there's some
other things that go in those slots but
this this is a big step forward
in for exotics being able to just slap
things like that so i'm i think that's
that's a huge change i didn't even
realize that to like the third time i
read the swab because i just kind of
glossed over it but
it's it's a big deal yeah oh
well the destiny that gamer he said how
could world mind cells work when
rasputin is reduced to being an exome of
mars and sunset
he's going at the lord he's good there's
some more
yeah well that's the thing too is like
if you want to use an exotic
again the war mine cell mods and stuff
still have their arc solar and void
and if you've like leveled up an exotic
are you still stuck with a point where
you have to like switch a more expensive
exotic to like
damage type yes i'm still wishing the
whole affinity thing would just kind of
fade we're getting part of it gone for
the weapon stuff but that affinity is
still
kind of limiting well the cool the cool
victory we got is like for example when
we run
like stuff like lucent blade and all
these other you know charge with light
stuff
remember the ones that would have those
extra secondary perks that will require
another
affinity of that element that's gone i
was not going but now it's easier
because it's like hey if you have arc
anywhere on your armor set right
then that now activates so they're
lessening the restriction there i think
this is cool
ultimately look i love running my
phoenix protocol
right you know it sucks to have to break
up
my whole charge with like synergy by not
having being able to slot
a mod there so that part is really cool
this is the right direction i'm
definitely happy for i'm pumped for it
but e we got to be greedy can't just
stop here
we have to get what we've been
clambering for we have to get
when it's time for the new artifact to
come out and they're talking about
overload and an anti-barrier
it is time for exotic weapons to get
that damn slot so i can dust off rat
king
i can dust off these exotics that don't
get no use
how cool would it be right like to be
able to put overload on a rat king or
you know bust out huckleberry when smgs
have something or
whatever it just there's so much
untapped potential and i know they're so
scared of
things breaking it but you got to let us
have fun let us have fun with stasis
like that's the last thing i need and
then i'm going to leave them all but
this did the armor here with this combat
mod
love it just now need the weapons to be
able to have
unstoppable mod all that other stuff
that instead of just limiting us to
these specific
legendary you know traps and that part
gets annoying but that's where i'm at
with it no i'm with you like i've we've
said like
almost every weapon at least exotics for
sure i mean yeah they have the ones
specifically for the season
but exotics especially because they're
exotic should just have a slot to be
and you could literally just have a
permanent pick of barrier overload or uh
why can i not remember the last one uh
unstoppable
yeah that's the unstoppable overload
barrier it'd be nice just to say
hey let me go grab any exotic
you only get one anyway and be able to
use that for that type of stuff i mean
we're getting
finally we're getting a heavy that can
break barrier so like that's a new one
so we're getting a little bit with some
of these exotics but
some of the old ones as you said
graviton lance you know pulse rifles are
probably going to be related to the
artifact this time around because
no time to explain is going to be in
everybody's hands but then graviton
lance
sits there and i can't use that for any
type of thing so it just sits in my you
know keeps collecting dust out there
at some point i'm with you like we need
exotics to be able to use these
anti-barrier overload and unstoppable
either freely for nothing just because
they're exotics and you can pick
or just because why not like if they're
gonna go through
champions in the vault of glass
i mean that's just that's gonna be one
of those things you gotta use it so you
may as well have a little fun with how
you kill it all
absolutely what's your stance on that
bob very curious like where do you sit
do you dig i'm gonna push back a little
bit let's
develop a talk i think i think having a
system
where you have a slot on exotics that
can slot
any barrier overload unstoppable
mod that is going to be too hard to
balance like i get that it would it
would probably be fun but people would
find like
the two weapons that are better than
anything in any context
and so it wouldn't really be about
experimentation people would just
immediately find it uh i don't think
exotics are ever going to get a normal
mod slot either because i think that
would be too hard to balance with all
the other mod slots
so i think this is going to probably
play out in either one of
two ways you're talking about graviton
lance but actually this season
we
so the solution is potentially
you have more armor mods that give a
certain class
of weapons whatever perk for the season
without like you didn't need you could
still you know use whatever
pulse rifle but it would automatically
be unstoppable because of the armor mod
the other option is that we get rid of
this whole mod system in general and be
like okay this season
all smgs are overload like you don't
have to put a mod like because
right now i don't even like like i don't
like taking off extended mag or
something on an smg
to make it um you know anti-barrier or
overload like i just i don't like losing
my mod slot for that just for that
activity
so i think you could just decree like
okay this season like
this weapon is overload this weapon is
you know anti-barrier
and just do it that way without mods i
think the artifacts
mod system is is getting a little
convoluted um
and it's a little little limiting so i
think if they took stuff like that out
and just made it
like this is the season of you know ars
being
anti-barrier that would be a little more
streamlined too
i i do not see them just like giving
every exotic the ability to be
anti-champion
in any context i i think that might be a
bridge
too far well i i don't imagine them
doing that
yeah reach for the stars and we might
make
yeah so like if we can get some
somewhere what you're talking about if
we ask for more
we might get somewhere of what you're
talking about but no i'm with you guys
and i did a
video on this a while back like the
artifact itself
we've had them for a year they're very
very samey at this point
there's two there's like basically two
slim and you have the anti-barrier
overload unstoppable
that's a choice and even as you said
like make that stuff intrinsic for the
season or it's like
you know auto rifles and you just know
which ones have it so you're just aware
of what's going on or if you just equip
that weapon and all of a sudden just
shows barrier down there because you've
got it
but it's like you've got two or three
columns on the artifact that are useless
one's always glimmer
[Laughter]
the most ridiculously specific stuff
like i'm gonna go grind glimmer no i'm
never gonna go grind glimmer that way
and the fact that it actually costs and
then i think you've said this before too
paul like
let us unlock if you are going to do
crazy stuff like that
unlock the whole thing feel like you'd
said it so i'm going to give you credit
no point in this 12 restriction i don't
i can't imagine because because all the
most powerful mods you can't even use
together because it's like
yeah some of them are six energy on your
class item or something so
you can't like you can't even use i
think like lucent blade and oppressive
darkness at the same time
it's one of those but so like
you could balance that with energy costs
if you really want to but there is no
reason to restrict it to 12 because
you're just automatically
disqualifying at least a half or two
thirds of your
of your mods and you're not giving
people like sure i'd love to play around
with like the
generate healing orb on precision kills
for a bow but like do i want to respect
my entire artifact for
40 000. just to get that
and like to change one mod i picked like
that's
that's not a good system and i do not
understand that would also be something
like throughout the season like it would
make the seasonal grind more interesting
because like as you leveled up
throughout the season or whatever like
you unlock
a mod every like other level or
something and it would give people a
reason
you know to to want to get through that
more when the current system is just is
not that rewarding at all
no plus past 100 you're like oh i get a
cosmetic every three levels
party oh that's a whole other thing yeah
they gotta do a whole
new system for post files
no one ever is going to respect the
artifact
because they need glimmer because for
one you have to spin glimmer to get it
and two it's like yeah that'd be the
thing it's like oh i need to get glimmer
well i have everything unlocked let me
throw a few things on there let me grind
out some faul
some hive and it's actually rewarding
glimmer dumps cool i got my glimmer back
up switching back out
that would be the only way anyone would
ever conceive of doing that right now
they're just like
you have to pick one in those columns
unless you just overload the beginning
and stuff like the glimmer ones those
should be passives like that they put in
the
season pass or something like there's so
many useless things in the season pass
as is like put some of those in like you
hit rank 30
and now hive knights give you know 5x
glimmer or something like
that would be cool things to put is just
like a passive effect
in the battle pass itself as opposed to
because no one's going to waste
a mod pick and a mod slot on that like
yeah
i i gotta have data on it too right
they've got to have the data on
you know now that the artifact has no
one picks those yeah
yeah like who's really out there
selecting that so yeah i agree they
should just allow us
those should be passives and they should
allow us to pick
what we want from the start because at
the end of the day paul made a fantastic
point like
i usually pick solar plexus sometimes
you know oppressive darkness all that
stuff
the cost is like six energy you can't
even
max that with anything else anyway so
it's just like yeah like that that stuff
needs to be cut out or they have to
improve the process
completely so yeah i i definitely agree
with that yeah that's one thing i'm
hoping for is just that artifact getting
just some type of rework because we
stared at yeah
next to the same thing even oppressive
darkness as well and this is the thing
too is like
hey oppressive darkness that's a very
popular mod the two times it's been in
there
everybody's got it we really like it
makes you use your void subclass which
is usually a little more support for
most of the characters
nova bottom separate but i mean you get
a like it
steers you into one but it gives you a
benefit from having that play style
they said at one point some of those
mods they're like hey the ones that are
favorites we're gonna make them
permanent
still waiting on that one to happen yeah
remember that yeah
yeah with any of the artifact mods i
feel like they haven't
i don't think so like i've haven't seen
in
that's like the idea of like the
permanent ones they did are like the war
mine cell
and and charge the light ones that they
added
um the ones like like surprise attack
and stuff
are permanent like the way they added
those like this season
um that's charged with light though
technically so yeah it's yeah
those are the only permanent ones
they've added you get like the seasonal
activity stuff you just have the charger
like the war mine have been here which
is those have been
interesting charged with light
especially is kind of cool and as it's
what is it charged with power
this fall because we're gonna have
darkness myself especially is kind of
cool
yeah we'll find themselves
now that you can't because they were
really heavily dependent on the one
artifact mod that spawned them on every
arc damage
uh yeah you could i mean you can still
do i still i sell the war might stall
build on my titan but
it's not as good as it used to be yeah
it was it was super strong man when it
first came out yeah absolutely
yeah they had some synergies going there
yeah charged with light is now going to
be charged with power mods because
i saw that in some little clip somewhere
because people were like charged with
power
because it's not light with light and
darkness power so if
yeah if you're running stasis you're not
charged with light so that was always
kind of interesting
but yeah like the final thing i would
just say is like the season pass and you
touched on it as well like the season
pass
of needs a little bit of love like for
you guys what would you what would you
like to see out of the season pass
and especially from 100 go ahead you got
your hand up
get rid of the damn exotic out of the
season fast yes
[Music]
like really that's that seems so you
want to devalue exotics you do it every
season
there's already so few exotics like
putting one in the battle pass every
time and there's only like
three a season is is and that's usually
the one you don't
end up using a ton other than maybe the
ariana's vow but like
tommy's matchbook and i don't what was
the one this season i don't know
i was with her okay it would have been
so much cooler to like
do a little do a quest for or find in
the wild or something like
i i do not like that um also in the
battle pass i i
hate the slots that are just like
your armor drops with more energy or
something because it's essentially like
like six instead of five legendary
shards that that is the equivalent of
like three legendary shards and like
you're dismantling it anyway
like ninety percent of the time and they
just they haven't changed like anything
about about the season pass pretty much
since launch and like
i i like i always like the grind up to
the artifact or the
effects the um what are they called the
cosmetic yeah cosmetics ornaments
yeah because those are always end up
being pretty cool like in the season
fast so that's cool to get up to the
high rank of that but like
just nothing else has changed like it
still has like the catalyst multiplier
progress and like the energy thing
and like there's like glimmer and the
crappy sets of armor you get before the
good stat
sets of armor it's just it's it's like
75 filler at least and it's just it's
not
remotely you know interesting in that
way
and that's no it's like and for me on
the same way it's like
we talked of recently that like we're
six years into destiny so some of this
stuff is getting a little long in the
tooth but the fact that these
have been so so samey for four seasons
in a row and it's like
here get your power i feel sorry for the
dude who was just bored out there doing
bounties where he's like
season past level 1400 or whatever that
guy was i've seen on twitter who's like
1120 power because he apparently didn't
have anything else to do
sorry dude because it means nothing like
as soon as beyond light starts it's all
gone there's
no no keep to that and it's like
temporary power is bad too
yeah yeah the temporary power and that's
one thing they said they're gonna like
work into the like look into the
bounties and the leveling system
we're a month out and i know they're
going to talk about the sandbox but i'm
waiting for them to drop news of
if leveling is going to change at all
because i mean as you as we've already
gone through the fact that a lot of
stuff is going on dcv
we're losing seven strikes if you gotta
go straight grind strikes your list just
got shorter
if you gotta go do crucible you're like
you're losing some maps but that thing
it's like gambit we're losing a couple
whatever you have to go grind now
is gonna probably feel even more samey
for those regular players
so i mean the whole bounty and leveling
and temporary power and all that stuff
i'm
i'm kind of hoping they go away with
some of that stuff because they've said
the infusion power is 1260 but the
artifact
maybe it's not i don't know those two
pieces the season pass and the artifact
have we've seen them for a year
and usually expansions won't get decent
changes
and i think this is the time that if
they don't i guess i feel like i'm
going to have a couple pieces of the
next year that won't be that exciting
either which will be kind of sad
yeah yeah shout out sanity he's saying
uh
he said here's the problem if they get
rid of the exotic in the past what could
they replace it with and we all know
it can't be the exotic cipher since you
can only carry one
that's it i mean it's a good question
again it just it doesn't
feel good if in my opinion if that is
one of the most valued possessions in
the game and then it's automatically
given to you
by paying you know say you paid ten
dollars so here
here goes this you know exotic it just
doesn't feel
like put it i mean at the very least put
it deeper into the past
like i something yeah so you can find it
yes you have to work for it
yeah i mean i know it's i think like 30
something for free to play
players but yeah just skipping it when
you buy it
yeah it feels very weird it just does it
doesn't feel good i i
really hope they get out of that i mean
i i think i understand the logic why
they did it you know they want
people in that that pass and how better
you know to give someone
an exotic but they to me they still have
to come up with a better way
and i just think that's not it you know
i i'm already i mean me
we already have this philosophical
agreement as far as
them showing too much right sometimes
like we feel like yo like
you know you don't get me wrong i'm not
gonna be mad but like
i'm such a fan but there's a part of me
that misses the mystery that misses
the getting the exotic in the wild no
one has it we don't know what the
properties are let's go test it there's
fun to that you know i'm saying this
exploration and i i missed that from d1
and now it's like you get the trailer
you get the instagram pic
you get the description and all its
glory and i'm just like all right
you guys will get them doing like game
you may be like all right
so gets uh content creators in here get
you guys previews of the weapon like in
action and stuff like that and
before any of us ever have it and that's
kind of exactly yeah i was like we have
10 exotics
do you guys think how we know hawkmoon
was like how many more do you guys
expect this
couple not a lot yeah it was like i know
forsaken was big
that's probably one of the biggest ones
forsaken of 13 weapons
and 12 pieces of armor yep i thought you
did that math
so we're not particularly close to that
i think at least eight armor pieces i
think they're going to do
or not eight um nine i think
okay yeah i i think they'll bring one
back from d1
and weapons i don't know i think there's
one or two hidden weapons but i'm not
expecting
13 weapons now like hawkmoon's not
listed which would get us up to
five and then yeah maybe one more if the
raid is not already
i would be surprised if they would give
a full description of a raid weapon
they teased like a thousand voices in a
trailer once but i don't think we
had like the full like this is what it's
called they did it for divinity
that's anarchy did anarchy we get it too
anarchy [ __ ] get any trailer love
yeah they gotta stop giving away like
secrets i think it's the ice one yeah i
mean yeah salvation is
yeah i made the speculation in my video
that it was like a fusion rifle because
i was reading projectile
and then as soon as i did like a lob
shot though yeah i was like and then as
soon as somebody's like it's a grenade
launcher i was like
well that's out there forever no it is
what it is
all the time because literally it's
portable stasis
it's this is it's potentially power and
you charge it up you get through like
multiple shots that go
kind of be curious how that one works um
i will say in the trailer for the
weapons
and armor we got the first tease it's
the overload shot where we got to see uh
walking harpy boy he actually got to see
the shot of him
and he's kind of big like he's bigger
than i don't know if he's
uh blanking today apparently my mind
doesn't work this morning
um minutes he looks kind of minotaur
sized like in scale
but with like all the flair behind him
he looks a lot bigger
us thirty-one pieces of flavor
shout out to destiny dad gamer i'm with
you brother get more catalyst man
i'm all about the catalyst for sure yeah
we already know the catalyst for no time
to explain that one's gonna make the
little
portal thing shoot faster in a preview
or pre-order bonus or whatever it is
deluxe edition
right yeah question i gotta oh yeah we
gonna talk about that too yeah
question before we get it today do you
do you think for the warlocks out there
who uh
usually run um ark souls
do you think you could have the ark soul
and the dotive to explain
thing at the same time you think so
first thing i was gonna try with it yeah
but that's what i was like jumping into
that yeah
it's a buddy system yeah no i definitely
don't know you're always up
yeah you think so oh
can't wait for the first six stack iron
banner team that's running double
buddies
just everywhere
wait um but no no no because it's it's
an exotic weapon and then exotic armor
is the one that where you can just
self-generate it at will
yes you can yeah you should be able to
do both yeah
yeah you're gonna have to get somebody
like stasis killed to get it to appear
so it might be that's true right so it
won't probably be quite as like on
you know trigger it i didn't read that
okay yeah it is stasis you're right yeah
i forgot about that there that's a key
detail
for the for the no time to explain one
to you maybe you can't
because if if you have to be a stasis
subclass
then maybe you can't do it at the same
time okay you might
somebody else could state this and you
could damage them potentially that might
be
how you get that wow then that would be
a pretty rare occurrence too
right yeah uh what is the effect to
summon a portal
which uh so it says precision hits and
hits against
uh okay so precision hits that not
specific and hits against uh
enemies affected by stasis will return
to the magazine stack this effect
whatever that like return to the
magazine stacking is
that will summon the portal so you got
to see i guess how many precision hits
you need to get
well and the orifice yeah if it's just
precision hits it will be possible
and getaway artist the the exotic yeah
yeah so i mean they're separate you'll
be able to do them both so it does seem
like it's going to be possible
yeah that's going to be weird i wonder
how effective double buddies will
actually be it just sounds funny to say
that though
i mean enhanced dark souls is no joke by
itself
yeah it's gonna be crazy yeah if you go
with enhanced plus that guy and then if
you have the catalyst and it shoots
faster you're just sitting there like
watching people die by your little
turret buddies constantly
there's gonna be some fun builds i i
think
i will be very curious to see with like
fragments and aspects and stasis
how how much different stasis feels than
the other subclasses because you get a
lot more customization you get builds
you do with something like that
it's going to be interesting to see how
all that stuff works together and all we
know is very little about it right now
sure yeah i mean theory
a lot of the exotics like we're not even
really talking about the whole fragment
thing but like you could have
yeah teleporting hunter exotic that
reloads your gun
and slows people near your telephone
all in one effect like that's that's
crazy
insane i don't think pvp balance is
really going to be a thing this
this upcoming season yeah to me it's
like
i i i had this discussion you know last
night shout out to the dancing pod guys
i was like
it almost feels that they said you know
what we don't care we are who we are
like like it almost like they had a
discussion in the balance room
and it's like you know what people like
mayhem they love that mode we look
you know let's just let them go because
i i really
again i'm all about the fun i'm i think
this is going to be so much fun
in pve i i love it but i for the balance
guys like when
trial starts with even the titan exotic
we were talking about right and then all
these stasis elements
it is going to be nuts
it's good man it almost feels like they
just said you know what
let let them have at it and whatever
happens happens and we'll deal with the
repercussions after something yeah the
first of the first
balance cash is going to be very
interesting very
interesting
uh but yeah i was going to say you guys
brought it up the fact that you've got a
catalyst in the pre-order
pack so if you don't pre-order and you
buy it like same day or a little later
how are you gonna is the catalyst like
farther away what's the grind on that
thing like
versus a pre-order catalyst this is like
a first for
not like paying for power but like this
is like a very
weird one that i haven't seen them do
before
do you have an annoyance i mean
i i can't imagine they're gonna make it
too difficult
to earn and find just naturally like i
i assume they've done this like the
giveaway of weapons in the past and like
it's never very hard to find them
you know in the game itself i don't like
particularly have a problem with this
like if the catalyst is broken
and like all the deluxe edition people
like are dominating and crucible for
everyone else
maybe but i don't really foresee that
happening so i
it's it's it's mildly annoying but
probably not
enough to write an article about
i was waiting for that i was like tazzy
go make that article
yeah probably not it's like don't need
to poke the bear too much
there's another dog complained about
oh yeah no he's got yeah he's got like
trucks and
fire and the police see they're not
happy about it right there see they've
got an opinion they're not happy yeah
the joys of living next to the firehouse
i don't know how you sleep man i'm just
two hours on a podcast every week i
don't know how you sleep you do work
next to a firehouse in chicago yeah it
was it was
loud frequently it's loud yeah i'm on a
near busiest
it is actually the other way but yeah i
mean it's interesting they made this
choice right with the catalyst i mean
i this is new territory i mean i'm i'm
not going crazy crazy but
you know it's what's the expression we
always say um
habitual line stepping like they just
slowly you know just slowly
push the envelope with certain things
and you know
i i think this won't get too much
pushback but um
you know i have my eye on them as they
continue down this path
what do you think like you think this is
getting into uncharted territory
i mean the uncharted piece of like
paying for a catalyst or the pre-order
bonuses we already get slapped in exotic
like right in our hands when we log in
on day one anyway
so it's not really too far removed from
that my honest worry is the fact that
it's that easy to get makes me worry how
weak the gun may be because they're
making it such ease of access that's
actually
guns that typically seem to be harder to
get like xenophages this full giant
quest and it's an absolute monster
versus
here's a pulse rifle with this little
like you know portal shooting
thing is like is it going to really make
that much of a difference
anyway that's my worry is that ease of
access means
less powerful could be wrong but it's
kind of one of those that i know if
that's
worried about that's necessarily true i
mean look at like look at terrible
i mean that's
yeah that's prime example
yeah generally speaking the rate the
raid ones are pretty powerful anarchy
thousand voices but i don't know if it's
like a hard and fast rule like wither
horde is slapped and your hands stay one
yeah that's a great
gun ariana's foul but then uh
tommy's matchbook was pretty garbage so
pretty good
i think there's some variance i i don't
i don't even know if they fully know
like how guns will shake into the meta
when they when they're making them so
well don't worry all the millions of
destiny players will
test their sandbox in about one day and
glad it's gonna tweet hey we broke the
game in like
five minutes i'm waiting to see how
what's the over under on hours you guys
have for
broken something in stasis um
because i know some people are gonna be
grinding but like
it's gonna be very fast yeah well yeah
we won't be all be unlocked first you
have to unlock it
yeah um so maybe maybe a little while
but
yeah it'll be fun man it's gonna be it's
just
all the cop people are gonna come come
up with some real creative stuff
and you know they they prepare for it
this is this is the route they want to
go i'm all about
the sandbox changing in dynamic ways so
there is a part of me that is excited
that they're going
this crazy to zany you know what i'm
saying so i want to see it in action but
yeah your best belief you know there's
going to be a lot of things that
people discover and break and you know
get into areas maybe they shouldn't be
and
stuff like that so we'll see how it goes
but it's going to be fun regardless i
feel
well it's always the days when we have
like 13 things to try and get through
and i feel like we've got to work
through a list we're
kind of getting towards the end i feel
like
anybody you're going to say like news
just broke on something
oh yeah he's
i will say this though um what i thought
i mean
not major major stuff but when they they
talked about the maintenance and they
talked about i thought that length of
time was interesting
well i mean we're gonna have to
re-download the whole game so it's gonna
be
slightly substantial yeah it's like what
is it like 15 hours of downtime
something like that no well
i'm not sure i'm not surprised given
what they're doing yeah we understand i
just felt it was interesting like this
is probably the most down time i've seen
you know what i'm saying
and um you know again all in my opinion
all that said we know what's happening
we know stuff's going into the vault
we understand the back end stuff that
were required that length of time but
this would be the first time i'm like oh
wow i'm not going to be playing
for a bit you know it's going to be
weird it can almost guarantee you
something is going to break
like i i think it's going to launch and
there's going to be something
wrong just just with the amount of stuff
they're doing and the amount of changes
they're making
i think it's almost impossible so well
yeah especially working from home and
testing
something slightly different yeah yeah
this is this is a big one the big
offline maintenance going on so
salute to the backup team if anything
goes wrong they've tested it
before and they were able to restore
things if they roll back and put take
everything out of the content vault
let's re-download the 120 gigabyte
version of destiny
oh that would be pretty terrible uh i
guess like do you guys expect there to
be a live event at the end of this
season
we've only got about a month left and
you have that before
i don't know i don't know how big it'll
be but i think there might be i just
have a feeling
but we'll see do you think it's just
like the director of the wings just like
explode and then it goes black slowly
explode
[Laughter]
that would be kind of awesome but yeah
it'd be kind of diligent um
i mean i kind of hope not just because
i'm a little burned out on those
uh but i i would like i would like there
to be a live event like the almighty
thing
that doesn't require us to do like a
million public events and doesn't take
like four hours to unfold like that
i'm hoping for some sort of event not
necessarily a community like
farm this a million times event but some
you know era ending event with all these
planets go in the vault or something but
yeah i would agree yeah yeah they had
like some type of cataclysmic
planet thing you know what i'm saying
and you know you kind of see that in the
login beyond mercury
at this time and like i just it's like
consumed by darkness or something like
yes you have to respond and you just go
to orbit because your ghost revives you
or something like that yeah exactly like
it'll be dope because i want them to
expand i think the concept
of the almighty event i really really
resonated me
you know obviously the execution could
have been faster but you know i i do
like that
so i want them to to kind of implement
that in world events and we know this is
a big one you know darkness is here they
arrive
pilots are going evacuation quests we
can get something like that i mean
hey that would be a cool implementation
we'll see
yeah that's kind of my hope i mean as
you said you're losing
not quite but next to half of the game
so i feel like it's got to go out in
some type of fashion not just like
servers go down planet's gone there has
to be some
explanation be it lore the pure the
pyramid ships are parked there for a
reason they're in the sky box for a re
there has to be something to that
whether it's just like
you look at the pyramid ship and it's
just this like blinding light or it goes
completely dark and it sucks the light
out of the plane
some way for them to do i don't know i i
think as you said though it's like
go here on mercury go here it's like or
are all four gonna happen at the same
time you just have to pick your planet
which would talk about
i would not be sure it'd be cool to do
it over the course of a week or
something
like each day planetary event i don't
think anything's getting destroyed
because
if they do want to bring stuff back out
of the content fault
like i don't know maybe it's just like
darkness quarantined or something but
i i can't imagine they're just going to
be like straight up obliterated
right just like
mercury yeah that can be obliterated
a little baby sparrow lap hey at least
it's a sparrowable lap now so you can
drive
it no
what's up justin what's up brother sorry
i'll tell you that building what's going
on bro
nice feeling chilling yeah man's over
here just like doing bench presses of
like houses over there he's cool
he's too busy making fun of my warlock
exotics
he's a beast yeah but that's i would say
like
for our guest sake since he's got all
the podcasts in the world he's got like
six more podcasts to do
yeah he's just podcast all day saturday
sunday
and i gotta write at least one more
thing yeah dude all of us all of a
sudden there's like
an episode hiatus after this after
tonight you deserve it you've earned it
yeah so well that was like
it always feels odd to like kind of have
so much to talk about and then yet
not have as much as we eat we
we've got all these like 10 weapons to
get through festival to talk about we've
got mods and we're all of a sudden we're
like
and then we can talk about food for like
45 minutes and like podcast goes live
weird stuff paul's all about the
business knock it out i get another
podcast to get to let's go
relax thanks that's gonna be good man we
got a lot of stuff to look forward to
looks like they're giving us a little
preview for the joint but it's like you
said like usually when it's these big
type of twaps
we get nervous everything especially but
we actually knock it out but when it's a
light tomorrow but there's nothing going
on
we actually go off for a tangent so it's
kind of funny but yeah i'm hyped man
this was a good week this was a good
week
you know a lot of information got a nice
trailer got a lot of stuff popping
and um yeah man i'm pumped i'm pumped up
like this is that
we're in that final stage those last
couple of weeks right before the release
and this is when the excitement and the
hype train starts um unfortunately it's
the preamble to
an absolute week of chaos for console
launches destiny and 14 other games at
the same time so
it feels like the calm before an
absolute literal just giant storm so
i'm excited it just would have been so
nice to be out in september like that
one
right now such a good time yeah
exactly thanks oh yeah do you guys
expect full-length seasons
they got i i think they have to shorten
them to some extent yeah
um or probably at least a week or two
depending on how it goes
but because i don't think they want to
keep this november
date for expansions no by definition
they would have to be shortened
[Music]
which is good because i think there's a
lot of dead time at the end of seasons
anyway so
yeah it was like they feel like they
sometimes stay a little long
as you said by a few weeks a couple
weeks something like that trim each one
by two
it makes it harder on them obviously
putting out content closer and closer
together which is
i guess an issue of would you rather see
like three seasons set of four but
either way
i guess we'll see when everything
launches but i guess we'll get all that
official stuff if we start getting
calendars and things
or we'll know how long the season lasts
to start gauging that as soon as we get
beyond light yeah
but we are officially at 10 o'clock
everybody we can uh
work on wrapping this all of you guys
out there and chat you guys have been
amazing today thank you all for popping
in
uh if you guys are new to the show um we
do this typically on fridays whether it
be mornings or evenings right here on my
twitch channel
um but our guest of honor man uh next
time you're on you'll probably be
over 8 000 articles so i expect nothing
left
at that point yeah actually i was like
the way he's on it so we get him back
here every so often
um trade dms and stuff but man it was
awesome to have you in
and of course it was on an amazing week
so bungie bungee treated you well they
gave you plenty to talk about since you
have all the podcasts oh yeah no it's
fantastic timing but no thanks for
having me again i always always love
being here hello brother well tell them
where to find you what you typically do
gotta gotta hype up that new channel you
got you know all that stuff
youtuber creator i know man making
videos
talking head videos and everything
amazing 2020
yeah um i am at poltassie on twitter
i tweet a lot uh mostly about destiny
and lately about gentian impact
i write articles for forbes you can just
google my name they'll show up there
and i have a youtube channel which does
not have a custom url
yet because i have problems with that so
just
look for my youtube link in my twitter
that maybe
it's the best way and then i wrote some
books on amazon you can check out as
well
so a lot of different places
oh you're always a pleasure man i have
to get around man it's always
always a good time always great takes
and you're on the side of the good guys
today so i'm very pleased
yeah yeah that's that was he was uh he
won the exotic battle today
yes that's my mayor right go buy this
people go buy
paul tassie's books you want a good
sci-fi book he's got five of them on
amazon
audio book form as well man take them
with you on the go you are the
read read one of these man's books
please
absolutely thank you hero killer 2 is
out there now that's the most recent i
think right
that's my new one there's one trilogy
and then one
two book series so far so any what's the
what's the future novel plans there's
just too many articles to consume your
writing
man i i've got a couple chapters into
like two different books but i i am
really falling behind in book writing
with so many articles and games and
shows right now so i
i gotta get back to it but uh it's it's
it can be a struggle to keep keep
motivated for for books and stuff so
like i'm working on i do like four or
five articles a day
there's the tv show drops like before i
even like know it drops he's got an
article done about the whole like review
show i'm like dude
did you like watch it from noon to like
and then crash i don't know how you get
some of those out so fast that's
impressive sometimes i get screeners but
uh
not that many but like i gotta watch the
boys finale today sometime i don't even
know about the time but i can't wait for
that
there's yeah there's always something
no doubt well cog where they gonna find
you what do you got coming up iron lords
any other podcast you're gonna
i'm i just do this podcast everybody
else in this one is like
i do multiple podcasts every week i'm
all over the place you can i'm just like
i'm just me today so tell them what you
got like
what's your other two podcasts you're
going to be on what are you going to do
you're funny elizabeth first of all
shout out to paul for color do a man
always a pleasure man huge huge fan
always honored to have you here
get your fresh takes and and talk
destiny's exciting time so salute to you
on that
and forbes is killing it man you guys
are going you're gold standing over
there for gaming
keep up the good work man huge huge fan
of your work um yeah for me manchester
lordcognito
on twitter you know what i'm saying i
love podcasts every sunday the lord's
day
11 actually this week 10 30 a.m eastern
special time
special guest we're gonna have uh
miranda sanchez from
hi she's gonna be in the realm so we're
gonna talk yeah it's gonna be real cool
man so check it out we're gonna get her
her journalistic history and then also
talk about the latest in gaming
playstation five tear down most likely
we're gonna talk about this potential
microsoft partnership with gamestop
seems kind of interesting
yeah and um yeah a couple other topics
in the gaming interesting
hey dizzy yeah i didn't even tell disney
like dizzy he's like oh yeah we got him
ready brad's gonna be she's good people
man salute to her so all yeah
please tune in again 10 30 8 00 a.m
eastern standard
iron little podcast on youtube and on on
twitch we simulcast
and the other podcast i do of course is
my man e
you know i'm saying the last word always
one of the funnest best
destiny podcasts to do and also guys
salute for all the support for lords of
gaming.net man
really we're starting to grow a little
bit as a young site get some stuff going
on man god recently opened critic and
some other things and salute to the
teams look to the writers dizzy's one of
our editors and jeeps he's in the chat
these guys again for the gamers by the
gamers doing a lot of great content some
cool articles up
thank you guys for supporting that's
pretty much all i got man shoot up to
the chat chad was on fire today i saw a
game in there
ares in there you know what i'm saying
like it was real cool to see man it's
good to see you guys supporting
the channel it really really means a lot
to us man he
puts a lot of work into man so what you
got i try i try to get it going but yeah
thank you guys this morning by the way
don't leave quite yet we gotta go send
the love to another twitch channel so
hang out after we finish the recording
we're gonna send a level
a couple other places uh but for me i
actually
uh did get to be part of the
outriders ambassador program so i am
going to be covering that so that was uh
kind of humbling and i was beside myself
when i got the invite and i was like
you get to a certain size on youtube and
you're like i get a whole lot of crap
spam i'm like
none of this looks real you try and be
like are you real for reply and you're
like
nope you're full of crap i got that
email and i was like
this actually might be real so then i
replied and like it
it's actually a real thing so i'm
excited and honestly like for looter
shooters and stuff like that it looks
like it's got potential with some skill
trees and classes so
another thing to sapling my time but
that thing is coming out february 2nd so
it's actually got a good release window
of space which i'm happy about so yeah
i'm super proud of you with that man
that that's huge i love that
you know lou to shoot a community we
need more representation again i love
what paul does because again
you guys are the the leadership of
keeping the john we're going you know
what i'm saying like i love it so
whenever i get your takes both of you
guys you know i really value it so e
salute to you on that minute that's big
outright is you know i got some
potential man so
i'm curious on your assessments and
breakdowns apparently i'm getting some
inside scoops so i'll let you guys know
as soon as i can
no nda's of course got to respect all of
those
[Laughter]
like that's one of those things you ever
get an opportunity don't screw it up
that's all you know that's
the best way to do it but other than
that you guys know uh right here on
twitch if you guys are new to the
channel uh hit that follow
button we do this every friday friday
amazing guest always paul thank you very
much i botched the start of the intro
but i think i finished it pretty strong
so okay more strong
how you finish of course incognito go
watch iron lord's podcast of course
amazing guests on there great chats and
everything so
man we have fun every friday and paul
it's always good to have you on i know i
talked to occasionally in dms about
random stuff but yeah getting to chat
with you for a little while
stealing you away for your 18 hours of
podcast man just save your voice get
some water with lemon and honey i don't
know what you got to do but
take care of the vocal cords and for me
of course yeah you can find me on
youtube twitch twitter it's ibontes
everywhere
um shout out to you guys in in chat with
some of the new sub badges the cheetah
paws are in there
man
yeah shout out can you not make the rest
of us guardians look as bad
you're too swollen kill everybody just
calm down
i still got the covert belly stop relax
well here's the thing you got your
buffer of 2020 if you don't if you don't
look pool ready by next like gardening
cone
that's on you you got like eight months
so i got a while to go i got a while to
go
so justin out there stays well and i
think we're gonna wrap this thing up
here and then stay i'm gonna finish the
recording and then we'll send you guys
over to another channel because we got a
lot of you guys we got to spread some
love so
for this episode of the last word
episode number 123 for october 9th it
has been
the last word